malloy you should be out there great now
those tourists did you the cutest thing
on the planet Malloy you know what I'm
talking anyone he's a dick
even your whispers sound fat how could
you say that Malloy does so many
thoughtful things for us yeah like what
like first starters he made that
delicious breakfast you enjoyed this
morning and don't forget he planned that
surprise party for Denzel surprise
bottom line if we don't get this park in
shape they're gonna shut down
brickleberry
so I've decided to hire someone to help
get this park back on track a new Ranger
old lady old lady old lady yes a new
Ranger she was Ranger of the month at
Yellowstone Ranger of the month
sorry
that's my vagina growling well okay I'm
really excited - I'm really excited
excited - oh you you're no den mother
you are here to take my Ranger of the
month title all along that seems highly
unlikely that that's what she's here for
you moron you keep a bear cub in the
ranger station Oh Steve brought him here
but I raised him as my own
he's a house bear there's no such thing
as a house big what is he eating
this diet will take years off his life
woody a bear cubs diet should consist of
berries Miller moths and grass well the
new girl's annoying
forgive me Malloy I failed you no more
junk pooper you ugly bear you took away
something I love now I will take away
something you love
[Music]